*big Chungus clap*
How do I start the video?
*LWIAY's amazing theme song*
Welcome to LWIAY, everyone.
Everyone's. Favourite. Show.
let's jump in!
of course the number one thing this week
brad
bye bye
everyone say "bye bye"
Brad has left the channel
This is so sad
:(
but the videos must still continue!
"Sive"
you are now "Brad 1"
no that's just...
You're finally Sive 1, congratulations
*happy music plays*
*community work from here pls, I just saved the other subs*
All the best and good luck for Brad
Wow that it's amazing!
that give me serious
shadow of the colossus vibes I really
want to build another meatball you ever
have that feeling when you're like I
want to build another meatball right
now right now I want to build another meatball so this is made of u/maskman
insane and that kids is how I Met Your
Mother
Now Frick
*laugh*
Do It! *clap*
I mean they did do it (oh yeah? ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
I realize the one that went into the
other cage is most likely it's so tiny
that it could escape and then he went
through the other cage and then he grew
up in there it all makes sense
they frick they frick
*laugh*
okay, yeah yeah yeah
this is the plan that we have on the
Minecraft series I have the Trident
actually that was a spoiler oh God oh
I had the channeling, and it's about to go down (get ready wither!)
and it's gonna be sweet in case you
don't know we're gonna frick the wither
with pigmen what am I talking about
I'm trying to unravel this video as if
you never seen my channel before and I
realize this is absolutely impossible
the amount of lore the amount of
knowledge you need to understand Pewdiepie
Maria:
wow you're up nice early
Felix knowing damn well he's been up all night playing Minecraft
I would if I could okay I'm literally
shooting this video early same thing last week
camera like he looks so tired
like yeah it's so I can play Minecraft
you don't understand
hey where's sven by the way
getting flashbacks here I don't understand your
memes (pathetic)
How I'm I suppose to understand this?
the original the
critically-acclaimed sequel the
underappreciated revision the failed
live-action the controversial spin-off
ooh the fanfic that went too far oh
it's gone too far it's definitely gone too far at this point
Hi sven, looking
forward to becoming friends oh no run
run while you still have the chance (dramatic flashback)
this is so mean. do you think
I want to live like this all alone and
no one loves me everyone dead hey you're
going to sleep yes now shit
what if Marzia inhaled a helium balloon hmm upcoming video idea
question mark I think she's done it
we've done it in a video Markiplier didn't
want to play undertale because people
harassed him for playing it the wrong
way don't do this with Felix and it's
minecraft series let him play how he
wants to play I'm pretty sure we've
established this but I do appreciate it
"NOW FRICK" I think that's what made the
series so fun people just wanted to help
out instead of being like oh this idiot
why you do it wrong am I really going
to defile this grave for money I needed
the money
I'll built ornaments okay it all evens
out it all evens out nobody: pictures in
every barber shop how do you guys find
this that's a dope foot as though like
that was that's pretty cool peace and
tranquility until "DINNERBONE!!!" bahahaha I love
these sober fanarts they just show how
dumb the whole thing is wouldnt it be
amazing no it wouldn't have been amazing
it would have been horrible and sad but wouldn't it been amazing if I actually
killed him "I found yOU" Felix you have
your Trident in your second house now I
don't I lost it in the water temple the
first time I went in I was like I'll
bring my Trident that'll be cool right I
died I lost said we don't have to talk
about it it doesn't matter okay at least
I'm being honest instead of just being
like oh I'll just spawn that in okay so
appreciate honesty
hello the last thing a villager sees
before gets kidnapped "GET IN THE BOAT" oh
my god you guys might said told me how
annoying it was that she posted her
photo and everyone just made peopIe
references and I was like yeah that is
really annoying and then I read the
comments "get in the boat"  "Marzia searching for Dinnerbone"
and I'm like that's actually funny Marzia's like wedding over Felix when you're
tending to your farm and some Swedish
man starts walking when you're tending
to your farm and some Swedish guy starts
complimenting your crops and whips out a
boat from his back pocket no matter how
far you've come
never forget your roots I saw this
someone someone didn't like fixing or
improving which is not fair
I will never be able to build like this
come on I do love the Atlas Shrugged a
statue that's really dope how Joergen 1 &
2 died so sad by the way how Bernie died
a goddamn hero never forget what Bernie
did for your country
nobody Shampoo advertisement damn she
must use a lot of that bamboo peepee
poo-poo has observed Pewds from the very
beginning he's been there since number
one before Joergen before Sven there's a
common fan theory right now that Peepee Poopoo
is whoever holds the saddle no one:
Pewdiepie when he sees minecraft meme:
I understand that reference I know where
this is coming from how long can we push
minecraft until it becomes cringy again
I'm just curious villager taking photo
after being kidnapped see I saw this and
that's when when that's when Brad went
bye-bye I was like this is the picture
armed robber wore Minecraft costume
police say- dude at the counter: AWWWW MAN
aww man and then he started flossin'
creeper aww man this is what went down
and then ali-a came in out of nowhere it
was epic it was crazy Pewdiepie cheating
other people cheating cheating for a
really cool base full of immense riches
cheating to feed peepee poopoo army the
meatball is real get it in your thick
skulls petition to have Pewdiepie put a Dutch
flag in the nether to make it
Netherlands that's genius that is the
smartest thing I've ever heard
what is wrong with nether what is wrong
with Dutch people while you're a country
like this I am inevitable and I am sorry
damn that's badass Loki this kind of
makes me want to bring Sven to the fight
against the wither *throws Sven a sword*
"here Sven go" "but I know don't how to use" "I saw
you in anime you did it" 2014 now I don't
believe in gods or anything 2019
PewDiePie: Oh Almighty water sheep give
us guidance give us hope show us the way
water sheep accept humble offering
minecraft truly has made me a believer
again it's getting pretty dark down here
hello I left him for half an episode
oh no he's died this makes it so much
sadder F's in the chat boys at least he
died for a good cars Adventure is out
there jack told me yesterday he's like
Felix I have to tell you something
you can put dog in boat and then you can
make horse go after I'm like really you
think I don't know they spend do
something bark incredible haha what I
don't know if it ever got posted here
but adventure time predicted water sheep
my God my God he exists in every
universe every realm there is a water
ship Felix when you turn the Peepee poopoo army into Zombie pigmen make sure
Sven is sitting at all times. if he's not then he will
try and attack pigmen that you struck
with lightning the Pigman will kill him
keep Sven safe! that's not Sven why you
waste my time they build some assassin
an army of 60 million subscribers an
army of nine-year-olds an army of peepee poopoo and I got so many comments about
people from like dude such a childish
name bro
grow up are you actually 9 I'm like yeah
yeah yeah
it's not ironic humor okay just cuz you
don't have the big brains to understand
an ironic humor and don't try to
criticize me and the boys rading area 51
me and the boys coming back damn
water sheep look hella freaky you asking
me add I'd ask if you're single Sive
when people still call him Brad - after
Brad stop editing for Pewds say sive
right now such a good meme sive don't cut
this out oh that's right now you can't
blame Brad if anything gets cut out
anymore
ah now it hurts how can I enjoy LWAIY
now if I can't complain to Brad here it is!
Peepee poopoo is not a name it's a title
given to the most distinguished swine
that is destined to lead the army
Walking Dead I killed 14 characters Game
of Thrones well I killed 37 characters
and Mateus I liked the cloak as well
amateurs
all my friends I kill in two weeks Pewds
will hit 99 420696 subscribers I don't
know if that's true but I'm too lazy to
check stuff that's awesome
hey guys 12-hour Minecraft livestream at
a hundred million let's get it go
subscribe goddamn it tell your friends
and family kids for the future here guys
Check out my STREAM DECK XL Elgato
can you see it it's actually really
useful now that I edit some of my own
videos I can put commands and open
different apps just by clicking buttons
*pling pling pling* open edit *blop* you see
that you see screen change open
photoshop *blop blip blop blip blop* it's
really cool i'll definitely recommend
checking out using a sound boards and
all that kind of stuff on with video
link description byE Pewds subreddit will
become the biggest subreddit in 2021
that's true but I'm too lazy to check I
like that meme template that's good
Pewdiepie your diamond swo- I don't have
time to read
I guess I'm kidding alright I appreciate
it thank you again? seriously? I get the
jOKE!
ha ha especially we need to get the
lapis you like blue! blue! is there some
kind of automatic fish farm I can make
this entire sub come on
well then tell me choose your superpower
flight invisibility fast control water
cloning that's is ability it all makes
sense
while t-series wanting subs Felix
wanting relevancy it's probably just
because you're subscribed and you know
it doesn't matter sure sure
whoa that's a strong cat sorry mr. cat I
still don't have a cat in minecraft I
woke up in the middle of the night Marzia comes over are you okay Felix
I still don't have cat in minecraft
Felix you need three babies so that baby
has bed too. before you get a third bed they
won't frick oh they fricked you just
gotta throw fruits and vegetables at
them they will fricky I know you guys are 9
and you want to try and tell me these
stuff like I don't know how to frick ok
throw vegetables get a bed put some
nice lighting and they will frick
everyone fricky smicky I can say
frick as many times as I want fricky
leekie picky YouTube what are you gonna
do I found a loophole in system frick
frick frick frick I hold the power now I
bet if we all said Frick enough that
would be the new F word when people
realize they can't blame - there it
is! haha what can your Minecraft chair
do this why have I not built this
alright I'm writing that down I'm
writing that down for my minecraft
letsplay see I saw this and it was
actually really helpful I appreciate it
so Billie Eilish's music publisher just
100% of the revenue from my
cover video it features no part of the
original recording on Spotify they would
only be able to take about 25 percent of
the revenue YouTube has made awful deals
given the industry music industry all
the power thank you
well put Joe oh you
this 10-minute original content video oh
I'm sorry we own half a second of that
money give me money mine
don't let Pewds forget that he has to
marry Marzia this year instead of
getting addicted to minecraft oh I'm
well aware it's really hard already
keeping up with everything I have an
idea for Felix water sheep wool that is
so cool since I just Pistons pushing it
through oh yeah doesn't look too
complicated either I can build that yeah
yeah that's so cool I think the only
problem is it's gonna be quite loud
isn't it having Pistons going constantly
dudes can't wait to show you all we have
dorky organ now that's right that's his
name did you really forget his second
house near the iceberg yeah it's ugly
okay let it burn is are we not gonna
talk about the irony of the fact that I
killed people poopoo with what I was
trying to heal him with isn't there some
bittersweet harmony there peepee poo-poo
and their dragon high effort meme took
me five second damn episode one he's
come so far I can't ride the pig are you
kidding me
Joyner smell of pee pee Rolfe my best
friend throughout the whole playthrough
say sack right now I just realize any
time I say my best friend my best friend
dies and friend is supposed to be my
best friend and he not die
Sven kill everyone just a theory pity
pine can making a cobblestone generator
for three video stream I'm sorry I'm
sorry for taking so long it's it's not a
I sure it's big brain time it makes
plague a load Felix play with Jack
physics play oh yeah I saw this in the
comments I've used it already
thank you it's actually really helpful
oh man
damn that's epic during the winter
battle Felix is going to accidentally
hit a zombie pigman and they will all
try this can't happen they are loyal to
me I birthed them I birthed them they
loyal God you guys make me cringe Pete
if I should get an orange cat in
Minecraft like his old cat schnitzel
what if schnitzel come from his name was
good stuff because good stuff means
Garfield in Swedish and he was orange
and it was also very effective when we
also didn't like him so no no thank you
how do you know about my old cat huh how
do you know can you make them fat like
that cuz then I want them if I can make
him fat I want them you could seriously
hurt yourself son please push me to the
edge old friends equals dead I have to
change the lyrics otherwise this video
gets copyrighted Thank You YouTube the
system is working perfect oh my god what
if Sven is killing everybody to be alone
with pizza forever this is literally why
I said our thoughts are like so sync
today my sis engagement ring how do you
guys know how do you guys finally stuff
when your name is the same as Felix dawg
it's free karma spend upvote saving them
their bone from the bottom of the ocean
or saving dinnerbone from felix by
hiding him tempeh come on he's safe not
he's been safe at least an episode and
that's longer than most people this game
is so anime damn oh my god
that's so cool
well and it's not how we went down by
the end that's awesome
that's so cool yes dark Jurgen everyone
it's so cute that's awesome
you can't defeat me I know but he can oh
no bad
20:43 3117 41 42 it is a lot of work and
I appreciate you guys appreciating the
extra time that was the sentence
apparently not only is there an Ikea
fish but there's also Petey Piper what
give give it Felix I did some redstone
of gabbro damn what is that
it's like people building computers in
Minecraft I read this book called the
three-body problem they make a computer
out of people like an army of people
just by making them follow certain
commands and always always make me think
of Minecraft how you can just make a
computer literally out of anything that
can listen to simple see I don't know
how to a computer works okay I just
think it's cool that you can actually do
that according to IMDB peer news is the
48th best show top ten let's go baby tub
Ted there it is thanks guys I really
really appreciate it
oh that's so cute you felt bad for them
YouTube trending again seriously you
can't stop minecraft youtube I fear no
man with that thing it's gays you should
be afraid we're coming for you with her
whether you like it or not sweat
survives eleven creeper explosions Felix
uses two totems home undying while
building
oh there's another one
oh I'm sorry IKEA bird you came for the
name tag on slimes and they want these
spot edit never mind he died why join us
roll ha ha ha ha ha can we appreciate
how generally happy is how much he
accomplished in today's episode I did
redstone it make me happy when redstone
works because it make me angry when it
doesn't fame power fat bank can't change
everyone or pet bed this is sad it's
when you're the new DJ sweat
alright gamers thanks for watching
another episode of lawanna thanks for
all the support thanks for checking out
the merch
everything you do has been amazing ever
since they played minecraft i've been
generally having so much fun and i hope
you had it as well i want to finish this
off by playing a song by part in the
backyard this will be the outer of this
video thank you guys for watching as
always see you next time
and you're Jurgen he is gone
you only have your spit here's your baby
your European ages gone
you openly ask your swissbear
here's your baby
what